let's talk about here 26 the I I thought
the story was really interesting
Pew Research has done a little study
they're calling the next america
basically what America demographics are
gonna look like in the year
2060 I read a book recently 2013 by
Albert Brooks and basically
it everything that he predicted but
they're saying it's gonna take an extra
thirty years
so let's look at some stuff here okay so
this is the
the racial breakdown and how it's going
to change massively and if you're one of
these white people that want only be
around white people
you're not gonna be happy %uh and 26 the
so by 2060 non-whites
will make up 57 percent of the
population
mainly because immigration ships but
also because the birth rate and things
of that nature
a and then what i think is even more
fascinating is this next piece we're
gonna show you
and I believe it animated okay so in
most societies
if you were to look at pyramid Europe
all the young people on the bottom and
then because people aged guy
it's a it's a peer mentor gets a per
hour over at the top what's happening
and what's going to continue to happen
in America because I've science
and because our shifting demographics I
is that we're starting to get a square
so we're gonna have as many old people
as we do young people which affect the
economy and it's going to affect
help they're all kinds of things bad
well earlier and
previous segment on the show yet talking
about the benefits have Logan's Run
at a run for her money and we're taking
the sanctuary yes threatened
and I the letter but this chart proves
be value
the societal value up government-run
with Michael York
well your Michael York that's right or
Logan's Run
and 2030 by our prototype hope they make
it to movie have sort of ridiculous
because what he was predicting
is that the next sorta civil war we're
gonna have is gonna be an age war
because young people are gonna be sick
about putting all their money to
existing all people who keep living
longer and longer
and there's going to be less young
people and more all people
but should we talk about the young
voters to the race when you feel infers
we first got my yes but before you go
back to the first chart
let's go back over to regular glossed
over that say
I just I just it and I was born in 1967
look back at nineteen sixty and we were
winning
me I we look at that white power any but
I am
nah that's okay I'll the prime any
Asians like who gives a shit they're
barely even here
it was great those are good they are ya
they barely
what the Jewish guys do in 1968 Yahoo
I don't know personally I'd here
I don't know is it about rate or is it
about
religion because you know what the more
you talk about this and you think
whatever I doubt this is politically and
said that I don't know I'm to bring I'm
brainstorming
yeah I'm here but you know that they
said the Hispanic population has
increased so much in wilt keep
increasing is that
because the calluses on is that like a
birth control because the
a politically I think it all I it just
seems like it more
it possible that it's more about that
than about actual race yeah
I don't know that's just my thinking
what do you make v
you know Bill O'Reilly always talks
about like the the old america the
fifties as it was so great that we've
lost our way since then but what he's
really talk about it eighty-five percent
waste away
that means really heartening that
without saying it 'em
do you think why people are gonna be
okay in 2016 for this is that
a realization by why people that they
can don't have to fuck only other white
I get the big
the big-hearted right that's a good
point everyone in that chart
can fuck anyone in that chart baths and
that would be a great thread to make
this all things everybody has to do
their part
create future people yet that I retired
in April I
very very much yeah I am okay so what
why people are gonna be okay but
what is it that you think that there
with wedding year where all the parties
with what do they
really their chain of the pier anna &
what and I'm I really mean that your
change
in the sense that they fear a loss what
their and
you know it's human instinct when
something was good and you feel it
slipping away
you wanna grab onto it and they're
trying to grab onto that
way of life they feel idly threatened
every time that you know be no black guy
raises fist in the air
or a Mexico or a salvadoran fights for
immigration rights
or agent goes to Berkeley well you know
I
and the funny thing about that is these
people who are trying to better their
lives better their circumstances
it seems that these particular people
these particular why people are taking
that
super personally right now it's not
about that it's coming from there
exactly right well but it is they're not
Inouye
if they're not totally wrong helen is
coming from them
and that you know what that's okay it
always came from somebody just went to a
different white person but
the whole every republican lately and
has run for president on that theory
have fear
and that fear is that things are
changing in the things you love doing
things you knew in the things mostly
that you could count on in the future
are being taken from you by the others
and
you know when the others work fourteen
percent wasn't that bad the others were
24 percent starting a lawn comfortable
now when the others are fifty Somerset
yeah like there's nothing we can do to
stop it so should everyone be embracing
it more than our society is gonna change
we're different ethnic makeup in the
nineteen fifties in
gonna change will be okay people don't
think that it's gonna be the same
that's what you're saying people don't
think it's well it's going to be more
agents gonna be more hispanic girl who
are black but
that it's totally the same people are
are filling in the blanks like
racist Madlib style about what goes
along with that change
and that other dude yet what do we have
a melting pot was initially about a
melting pot
rather a retired what about that melting
pot whenever I think I mean it did not
think it was a great great concept a
poetical
detailed bill o'reilly look in the pot
you know he was like holy shit
parties ok and brown number you gumbel
but and for republicans it's gonna be in
their do
when he likes you know what I'm by Matt
this melting pot as long as the bra
right totally project leads a very clear
bra
yeah but their home and less take me
really calls for policy change because
and significant policy changes because
there's none as long as they're seen as
hostile
latinos their deal that they have to get
a significant portion of that and the
only way we gonna do it
is by having some policy recognitions I
think that's gonna
I think they'll do it because I think
the need to survive ultimately
will win out but there's no possible way
to hang onto
electoral majorities without cultivating
some minority vote and is Gina said
there's you know
the lack a birth control strong families
deeply religious values there's a lotta
reasons to think that republicans could
latch on
sure to plan the ability to better are
you implying that that might be why Jeb
Bush said that immigration is an active
love do you think it was a
calculated political I am well yeah I
mean it was gagging political movie
might also be like that but it's the
other way
right you know up iight opine about the
age thing which I actually think is the
most interesting part is cuz we talk
about race all the time
are we could have a major problem
feeling
with old people because brighter to
decipher I
a I believe me I I love the golden rose
more than ever but I am I gonna start
dating oh people
because they're gonna be mooching off
the system we're gonna be on left young
people putting money into the system
and these people because I did gonna
keep living longer and longer and longer
it also creates the sort a vicious cycle
because
you know people are gonna wanna start
you know having families in supporting
in a little teeny tiny top if they're
already putting so much money into
supporting their parents their
grandparents other people's grandparents
right so
which we already see now believes are
having kids way less even rednecks are
having kids
way later than videography great movie
yep now bearing that so many actors you
my sexiness to be
I have a really the lab a I care about
the cautionary
yeah it is by removing no week but that
the
one Obamacare is a the is critical for
this
because you get young people forced to
pay forced to buy which will help pay
for
right i mean it's incredible that was
significant porphyry in that
plus and as the black males to take out
some take that back
Rob Missy it's all going to work itself